[Music]
think lightly of yourself and deeply of
the world
[Music]
it is difficult to understand the
universe if you only study one planet
perceive that which cannot be seen with
the eye
[Music]
today is victory over yourself of
yesterday tomorrow is your victory over
lesser men
[Music]
with your spirit open and unconstricted
look at things from a high point of view
[Music]
do not regret what you have done
whatever the way the master of strategy
will not appear quickly
[Music]
it may seem difficult at first but all
things are difficult at first
the way of the warrior is Resolute
acceptance of death
from one thing no ten thousand things
as you get the Rhythm you discern how to
win
it is bad for commanders and Troopers to
have likes and dislikes
[Music]
foreign
it is wrong to be inflexible
[Music]
both in fighting and in everyday life be
determined through staying calm
[Music]
do not let the enemy see your spirit
[Music]
do nothing that is of no use
[Music]
you may abandon your own body but you
must preserve your honor
step by step walk the Thousand Mile Road
develop intuitive judgment and
understanding for everything
foreign
become acquainted with every art
[Music]
do not let yourself be guided by
feelings of lust or love
I live by choice not by chance
[Music]
do not let the body be dragged Along by
the mind
or the mind be dragged Along by the body
get Beyond love and grief exist for the
good of man
[Music]
respect Buddha and the gods without
counting on their help
[Music]
you must understand that there is more
than one path to the top of the mountain
if you know the way broadly you will see
it in everything
[Music]
if there isn't discipline How can there
be a true realization of an ideal
truth is not what you want it to be it
is what it is and you must Bend to its
power or live a lie
one thousand days of lessons for
discipline Ten Thousand Days of lessons
for Mastery
[Music]
in battle if you make your opponent
Flinch you have already won
you can only fight the way you practice
if you do not control the enemy the
enemy will control you
[Music]
the important thing in strategy is to
suppress the enemy's useful actions but
allow his useless actions
[Music]
the only reason a warrior is alive is to
fight and the only reason a warrior
fights is to win
to become the enemy see yourself as the
enemy of the enemy
[Music]
know your enemy know his sword
when your opponent is hurrying
recklessly you must act contrarily and
keep calm you must not be influenced by
the opponent
one must make the warrior walk his
everyday walk
[Music]
in strategy it is important to see
distant things as if they were close
and to take a distant view of close
things
[Music]
in strategy it is necessary to treat
training as part of normal life with
your spirit unchanging foreign
the purpose of today's training is to
defeat yesterday's understanding
[Music]
study strategy over the years and
achieve the spirit of the warrior
[Music]
the path that leads to truth is littered
with the bodies of the ignorant
you win battles by knowing the enemy's
timing and by using timing that the
enemy does not anticipate
[Music]
in time all things work to your
advantage when you pursue them with an
open heart
if you do not look at things on a large
scale it will be difficult to master
strategy
[Music]
even if a man has no natural ability he
can be a warrior
foreign
[Music]
there are many ways of understanding
simple ideas but generally the opposite
is true of difficult ideas
when you attack the enemy your spirit
must go to the extent of pulling the
stakes out of the wall and using them as
Spears and halberds
it is bad to repeat the same thing
several times when fighting the enemy
foreign
do not collect weapons or practice with
weapons beyond what is useful
[Music]
no man is Invincible therefore no man
can fully understand that which would
make him invincible
[Music]
polish your wisdom learn public Justice
distinguish between good and evil study
the ways of different Arts one by one
it is better to be a warrior in a garden
than to be a gardener in a war
[Music]
of course the void does not exist
by knowing what does exist you can know
that which does not exist that is the
void
[Music]
if you are not progressing along the
true way a slight twist in the mind can
become a major twist
this must be pondered well
what is essential is to think that
anything you are doing may be eliminated
you must examine this well
the warrior is the twofold way of pen
and sword and he should have a taste for
both
all men are the same except for their
belief in their own selves regardless of
what others may think of them
a man cannot understand the art he is
studying if he only looks for the end
result without taking the time to delve
deeply into the reasoning behind the
study
[Music]
it is difficult to realize the true way
just through sword fencing
know the smallest things and the biggest
things the shallowest things and the
deepest things
[Music]